mais il y a mes amis qui sont morts
Je ne mange pas, je suis venu pour me venger
se venger spécifiquement
[musique]
nous avons vite fait notre travail machine
évacuer rapidement en conséquence
Nous essayons de nous blesser avant
frappe
le normal a déjà été emmené à l'hôpital
un hôpital normal à part entière
en salle d'opération, ce temps est maximum
il est important de le réduire
[musique]
Ne le mets pas dans une telle situation et ne te fais pas prendre
Ce n'était pas ici
complètement toutes les situations il y a des renflements mais c'est tout
il y a trop longtemps maintenant
brocart de la nuit ça avait l'air effrayant
Peur Peur
[musique]
ceux qui travaillent
pour eux c'est le premier objectif
[musique]